Jason Statham can indeed act I knew it
was true I knew it was true redemption
or hummingbird as it was originally
titled stars Jason Statham in this movie
is about a guy who's sort of down and
out the movie starts out with Jason
Statham and he actually has hair it's
very interesting to look at it it's very
it's a little confusing he's homeless
he's roaming the streets he's trying to
protect homeless people he's basically a
good Samaritan but at the same time he
needs help he accidentally lands in this
guy's apartment who he finds I was on
vacation and he decides to live in this
apartment for a while and try to figure
out a way to clean up his life all the
while he's getting to know one nun who
works at this homeless shelter who feeds
homeless people and at the same time
he's kind of becoming this pusher for
these various drug and gang related
organizations and which he's the guy who
comes in there and says we need the
money right now I'm gonna kick your ass
essentially that was my best Jason
Steele impression not very good sorry so
the movie really is about a character
who's trying to run from his past trying
to be a better person trying to start a
new relationship that leads to something
good and I was interested in the film
for a while but the problem with
redemption is not Jason Statham who
actually gives one of the best
performances of his career in this movie
the film feels a little bit messy and a
little bit convoluted it's trying to be
a lot of different things it's trying to
have some action scenes to please the
Jason Statham fans but it's also trying
to have a sweet romance in there that
well at times interesting and does have
some good chemistry these two things
don't really feel like they're cohesive
or the movie it's a good-looking movie
the nighttime photography is really
impressive and as I said the
performances in this movie are really
strong but it definitely suffers from a
lot of pacing issues because it feels
like when the film is starting to pick
up with a type of film that you would
think it would be it retracts and tries
to be more emotional which is great that
Jason Statham is really going for that
but this film needed a tighter script
and tighter direction to really be able
to sell these multiple storylines
because when certain emotional arcs hit
in the movie well the performers were
doing an excellent job I didn't really
feel the emotion that was supposed to
come with that because the movie itself
is way too jumbled to be able to support
all of these dramatic and at the same
time action heavy things happening that
being said the performances in this
movie
are really top-notch and I was really
impressed with especially Statham that
guy needs way more respect than people
give him honestly even though a lot of
his movies are generally the same
character or sort of down-and-out guy
you feel bad form
he's kicking ass at the same time
there's a girl it's usually there's
certain things that are all in the Jason
Statham code book and they're in this
movie for sure I don't mind that if the
film is told well and this film could
have used some editing and some things
cut out some storylines that didn't need
to be there and a better focus on how
the movie would be told
overall I'm gonna give Redemption a C+ I
think it might be worth a watch at some
time especially if you're a fan of Jason
Statham but it's not one of his better
movies but it's certainly better than
Parker his last film I actually truly
enjoyed safe that came out last year I
think that's a really underrated movie
if you're a fan of Jason Statham and
haven't seen that yet or just want a
good action film that's actually really
well directed check out safe
so thanks as always for watching guys if
you liked this you can click right here
and get stuck menage